welcome to my list of the top things
that python noobs do i'm also giving
away four professional licenses to
pycharm so comment hashtag pycharm if
you want a chance to win
some of these are actual issues for your
code but a lot of them don't actually
matter much
nevertheless these things will tip
people off to your inexperience so
whether you're an actual noob looking to
get better or if you just want to catch
any newbie habits that you still hold on
to let's dive in
alright newbie thing number one manual
string formatting aka putting things
together with the plus sign
instead use f strings they're more
readable easier to write and less prone
to errors
number two manually closing a file i
can't tell you how many beginner
tutorials recommend doing something like
this open the file write to it and then
call close
if this right call throws an exception
the file will never be closed instead
use a with statement which will ensure
the file is closed even if an exception
is thrown
on a similar note number three is using
try finally instead of a context manager
i usually see this one from more
experienced developers but coming from a
different language
in python most resources that need to be
closed have their own context manager
use it
number four using a bear accept clause
in python keyboard interrupts and system
exits are propagated using exceptions
that means for example a bear accept is
going to catch something like the user
hitting ctrl c that's almost never what
you actually want to do if you still
want to be lazy but you don't want to
trap your user in a box then use an exit
capital exception or if you want to do
the right thing then catch the actual
exception that's going to be thrown
number five thinking the carrot means
exponentiation nope it's bitwise xor
okay that one's a really newbie one but
i gotta pad the list somehow right
number six is any use of default mutable
arguments argument defaults are defined
when the function is defined not when
it's run in this case that means every
call to the function is sharing the same
list meaning the second time we call it
it's not starting out as the empty list
it's starting out as the list containing
zero from the previous call probably not
what you wanted if you want a mutable
default first set it to none and then
check if it's none inside the function
setting the default there number seven
never using comprehensions or if they do
use comprehensions only list
comprehensions a lot of code can be made
both shorter and clearer by using the
comprehension
you can have dictionary list set and
even generator comprehensions learn how
to use them when they're appropriate
number eight always using comprehensions
i get it you just learned about
comprehensions and now it's time to flex
but
stop for a moment you don't need to turn
every single loop into a comprehension
sometimes this actually makes things
less readable i guess readability is
really in the eye of the beholder so you
may not agree with this particular
example
but i hope you can agree that not every
loop should be turned into a
comprehension number nine checking for a
type with equals equals there are some
rare cases where you do want to do this
but most of the time this is not what
you want the reason is inheritance a
named tuple is a tuple so this point
class is a tuple but it's not literally
the built-in tuple it's a subclass in
most cases you should program in a way
where you should be able to substitute a
subclass for its parent
this is called the liskov substitution
principle and checking a type for
equality is a violation of it in most
cases what you probably wanted instead
was an is instance check
number 10 using equals equals to check
for none true and false instead of
equality you should check for identity
using the is comparison
this is what equals equals was going to
do anyway so just cut out the middleman
and use is directly
11. using an if bool or if length check
there's nothing particularly wrong about
these it's just that they're usually
equivalent to just a plain if x so using
an if bool or if length check kind of
just shows that you don't know the
language that well number 12 using the
range length idiom
a lot of beginners especially those
coming from other languages think about
loops in terms of indices so they loop
over the indices but only ever use them
to grab out the elements instead just
loop over the underlying container and
get the elements directly it's much
easier to read and less error prone if
you did actually want to use the index
though you still shouldn't use range
length use enumerate to get the index
and the element at the same time another
reason i see people use this is to use i
as kind of a synchronizing variable to
get corresponding elements from two
different objects of course the better
way to do that is using zip
and if you still need the index use
enumerate zip
number 13 looping over the keys of a
dictionary
don't you know that's the default
if you're modifying the dictionary as
you're looping over it then it would be
okay to make a copy of the keys
depending on the situation this might
add a little bit of clarity but even in
this case the dot keys is unnecessary
number 14 not knowing about the
dictionary items method if you're
looping over the keys of a dictionary
and the first thing you do is grab the
value out for each key then what you
really want is to loop over the items of
the dictionary which are key value pairs
number 15 not using tuple unpacking do
you have a tuple and one to get all of
its elements out as separate variables
well you're in luck that's exactly what
tuple unpacking does number 16 creating
your own index counter variable if
you're starting at zero and adding one
to something at the end of every loop
then once again what you really want is
enumerate number 17 using time dot time
to time i think we got to give the noobs
a break on this one how are they
supposed to know that time.time is not
for timing your code time.time is for
telling you what time it currently is
and it's not as accurate as using perf
counter subtracting two subsequent calls
to perf counter gives you the most
accurate way of measuring how much time
it took your code to run number 18
littering your code with print
statements instead of using the logging
module you can set up logging easily in
your main function with your own custom
format you can also set the logging
level or take it as a parameter so you
can filter out messages that you're not
interested in
there doesn't that look a lot better
19 using shell equals true on any
function in the sub process library
shell equals true is the source of a lot
of security problems and let's be honest
the reason you probably did this in the
first place is to avoid putting your
arguments into a list number 20 doing
math or pretty much any kind of data
analysis in python
learn to use numpy for array operations
and learn to use pandas for more general
data analysis
21. using import star outside of an
interactive session
import star usually litters your
namespace with variables instead just
import the things you actually need
number 22 depending on a specific
directory structure for your project a
lot of beginner code assumes that all of
your source files are going to be in one
flat source directory they probably
unknowingly are depending on the fact
that when you import something
python checks for it in your system path
python also adds the directory of the
file being run to the path so this
usually works
however this can really get you into
trouble if you have multiple scripts
that aren't in the same directory
take the time to learn how to package
your code and install it into your
current environment
number 23 the common misconception that
python is not compiled
have you ever seen those dot pi c files
next to your pi files or maybe they were
in a pi cache directory those files are
compiled python code but of course
python is also an interpreted language
so what's going on well python is
compiled but it's not compiled all the
way down to machine code instead it's
compiled to bytecode
that bytecode is then run by the
interpreter number 24 not following pep8
pep8 is nothing more than a style guide
it doesn't actually affect your code at
runtime nevertheless your co-workers
contributors and friends will nag at you
incessantly until you conform at this
point whether it actually looks better
or makes any difference at all is kind
of irrelevant experts do it this way to
avoid the nagging
and i saved the best for last number 25
pretty much anything to do with python
2.
python 2 hit its end of life years ago
and the only reason you should still be
using it is if you already have millions
of lines of python 2 written and it
would be too much work to migrate
all new projects moving forward should
be using python 3
and with that comes dispelling some
rumors leaking over from python 2.
even though x is really big this code
will execute instantly ranges are not
created in memory even checking if
something is in a range will happen
quickly given the endpoints of the range
you don't need to construct all the
numbers to tell whether something is in
that range you just check how it
compares to the boundary elements and
that's exactly what this in does there
are also things like the change behavior
of keys this no longer creates a copy of
the keys of the dictionary instead it
produces a view that means if you delete
a key it'll no longer be in the view
either
there are so many of these python 2-3
things that have changed it could
probably be its own whole video so just
always be sure to check the docs if
you're not sure
as always thank you to my patrons and
donors for supporting me if you liked
the video don't forget to comment
subscribe and slap that like button an
odd number of times and if you
especially liked the video please
consider becoming one of my patrons on
patreon
thanks and see you next time